s'est demandé ce n'est pas faire un
petit tour de table en rapport avec
notre chef adoré qu'on aime tous la
bouffe cyril
ils ont failli oublier et l'idée de
savoir ce qu'on avait vécu comme comme
aventure avec avec pochette alors où on
a des propositions et vous allez
retrouver qui a fait quoi alors
aïe vente cyril a refusé
cyril a refusé a
refusé pour une augmentation
syrie c'est vrai mon la boîte à sion non
c'est une plaisanterie
dure qui lira jamais de notation et
c'est vrai les moyens il est ingénieur
de notation mais c'est normal quand on
est aux états généraux des chars et
voilà
pourquoi attendre de l'argent quand on a
de l'amour
voilà exact mais très bien
vous voulez revenir alors on va vous
mettre les compositions bien évidemment
j'ai failli être le colocataire un
colocataire de série juste là alors
alors que locataire le coup
j'ai faillit le colloque est non alors
alors c'est vous oui alors pas
colocataires locataires tout simplement
pourquoi maxime gagne à chaque fois
c'est ca copé en fait c'est ça ce n est
pas qu aux locataires il a failli être
locataire oui allocataires parce que je
cherchais un appartement désespérément
parce que quand on est chroniqueur et
connaît les contraintes saison compliqué
d'avoir laissé des donc difficile de
trouver un appartement et me dit maxime
je peux trouver sans problème un
appartement tu choisis l'appartement je
l'achète et tu habites dedans donc vous
laisser au téléphone tu là attention ce
premier étage voudrais pas le 2e 3e
étage mais ça montre la générosité de l
ascension pavés ou ses places et upa la
venue de st du coup et au final
on s'est pas mis d'accord sur le loyer
et finalement j'ai trouvé une super
opportunité d'accords alors oui comme
quoi et il peut tendre la main au bon
moment ah bah oui il tend la main il
enlève un mois j'ai dû louer un
appartement mais j'adore les tableaux
j'ai pas j'achète des tableaux de jeunes
artistes ils sont pas connus mais je
voulais planter chez lui un possible
tous les murs et en marbre j'vais pas
planter assez le clou d'un appartement
de syrie
ça veut pas clouer j'ai volé des
chemises de cyril c'est toi ça alors
malheureusement j'ai malheureusement je
n'en faisais pas avant et j'aurais dit
montiel mois non non non non pas du tout
nicolas est très classe avec les
chemises et comme un voleur du droit à
bout la raison reste à jean pascal non
non c'est moi non parce qu'elle vous
n'êtes pas là que pour bouffer du gâteau
j'aime ces bouilles pas non
c'est vous
il faut savoir que c'est la grande mode
des chemises un peu oversize et sert il
à 450 milliards de chemises donc si j'en
prends une franchement il ne verra
absolument rien et sauf que après j'ai
un peu goût donc
j'ai
sonné banon et samatan et ben oui c'est
moi mais son repas ses propres rêves je
peux les restituer c'est que céline ne
remet jamais la même tenue à l'hôtel
donc en disant de tp tpb vous miner
nombre de chemises en rappel la peste
c'est incroyable incroyable slip ces
deux noms
merci jean j'avais ce qui est ma vie
pour cyril a alors un peu tout ça c'est
ce qu'ils ont annoncé on va découvrir
qu'en fait tu es idiot vers la pente
mais bon
comme c'est moi ç'a brassé ses bougies
en vie oui non j'ai pas risquer ma vie
du ton et en tunisie et évidemment cyril
amène janvier a changé alors c'est en
tous cas
complètement star bpt fou alors c'est
vous offrant quelques mois mais oui
alors papa raconte si toi aussi tu l'a
sauvé la vie moi ça m'a sauvé la vie
mais c'est un peu pareil c'est risquer
ma vie la coroner alors moi j'ai risqué
ma vie donc je remets le contexte on est
en 2019 on part tous en tunisie et
l'idée de cyril sait qu'on doit aller
chercher du lait de chamelle dans le
désert ça mais pour ça il nous dit on
doit prendre un avion sauf cas pas
d'avion qui va dans le désert je ne sais
plus pourquoi il ya aucun avion
disponible simplement un avion militaire
avec aucun siège à l'intérieur de mec
qui parle aucune langue qui font des
signes à une embauche mais vous une
transe vous prenez pas tout cas il
n'avait pas envie de me parler je leur
demandais si c'était dangereux il me
faisait des signes comme ça mais
poussive
mais je suis quand même monté dedans
après avoir vomi aux chiens on va
pleurer dit que j'abandonnais tout ça
mais je les fais et voilà je m'en serais
vous à mon sens donc en fait quand vous
prenez un avion vous pensez que vous
risquiez votre vie vous oui mais c'était
pas un avion voyez la barbie la viande
barbie qui veulent y avait des roses
ouais enfin vous avez une phobie de deux
cités pas même volume on prend un avion
s'était
alors dit m cent militaires ouais super
on va avancer alors
comme ça
voilà au maître jean-jacques alors qui
sait qu'un jour on y va alors bon sorte
alors le début alors cyril m'a sauvé la
vie
film a sauvé la mise ou peu exagéré mon
et en tunisie là aussi et voilà est le
but de ces îles toujours c'est de
préparer des happenings des choses un
peu des tracts à ela en fait ils avaient
préparé un tracteur pour nous dire qu'il
avait fait creuser spécialement pour
l'occasion une sortie et non de tombes
de nos normes de tombes avec de la
mélasse au fond des bambous piquant et
c'était un passé c'était un truc c'était
un piège
mais heureusement cyril vous l'aimez pas
renié j'étais avec kelly cyril est
gentiment comme un jeu rassemble depuis
très longtemps rien regretter dans la
voiture du père des clins d'oeil sont du
genre quand on va s'arrêter faussement
thann à me va pas tout droit et cetera
fais moi confiance et je me disais mais
tu as des taux courts à être pas de
bouger comme ça pas en fait c'était pour
mieux piéger kelly qui évidemment à
foncer droit dans le
regard
[Musique]
c'est rien t'as rien il rappelé a rien
à rien qu'il n'ya rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que ma tasse crise et la naïveté
phillipson s'arrêter en plein désert
près d'une route comme ça et il y avait
comme par hasard des gens qui les
attendaient des filles qui avaient comme
saga lunettes cassées et d'étagères
tajine etc et une rangée de pneus et du
fond milieu à cinq milieux elle sait pas
douter une seule seconde qui avait un
piège bon allez je suis allé le joueur
alors j'ai chanté en duo avec cyril il
ya vingt ans j'ai chanté à le chanteur
d'u2 la table
le pavarotti de nganda excellent il ya
vingt ans parce que j'étais chroniqueur
sur une émission bien croire mais vrai
il faut savoir il a démarré en faisant
le pitre et moi je faisais 8 rossi et
les pitres soit on est une belle photo
regard trouvé ça ça c'est une vieille
folle assez encadrée par envoyer tes
souvenirs et voilà tu vois ça c'est une
belle eu un beau dossier sur silva conte
enchanté koala bon on doit dire des
conneries comme d'habitude mais c'est un
bon moment avec syriennes après la star
ac juste après c'est j'ai rencontré ce
tir il a raté la grosse vedette avec la
wii non non jamais une croix dessus
sinon même si
les gens parce qu'elles ont sorti de
star ac c'était 3 bat wil corps télé
mais
je n'aime pas aller prendre une pizza
chez pinault jamais rien
fait de la non plus et que les frites
sont toutes folles de joie mais voilà
amoureuse de lui quand ce thème merci de
tout
[Rires]
civil m'a pris sous son aile sans même
me connaître à un peu tout le monde ici
simplement des
sénégalais ah oui bah non mais c'est
mignon non mais moi c'est mignon parce
que j'étais vraiment beau mais non
vraiment j'étais paumé dans ma vie
j'étais pas bien et tout ça je sais
vraiment pas bien et j'ai monté ma
société puis j'ai galéré et où puis je
monte chez les élèves ce tour et puis
j'ai essayé des marchés un petit peu les
chroniqueurs tpm p&c harcelée chaque
jeune a way à chaque fois il me voyait
passer dans les loges comme ça il sait
qu issa le consulat et tout moi et
j'étais trop timide le prévoit que j'ai
vu mais moi parce que j'habite à
juan-les-pins donc dans le sud cyril si
ça c'est à huawei vraiment ctpm pc mis
fin à près partout en france d'ailleurs
mais mais voilà je pensais vraiment pas
le voir un jour dans ma ville quoi à
l'époque et est donc et un jour il me
regarde puis je tremblais il me dit mais
tu es qui toi en fait et là je dis bah
moi je sais pas en fait je viens pour
travailler et je veux juste travailler
il m'a dit tu veux travailler chez louis
m'a dit bon prends mon numéro à partir
d'aujourd'hui site à n'importe quoi tu
m'appelles donné mon numéro
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
enfin série m'a planté en plein match de
padel à
l'organique off et votre vie quand même
joyeuse à vous avez très joyeuse mais on
n'avait pas joué depuis très longtemps
et un jour je me tiens on fait une
petite partie mercredi est ce que ça te
branche et will be ok très bien et au
moment où ils arrivent sur le court ils
me disent bon alors ça y est tu sais
jouer maintenant donc tout commence à
mettre la pression un peu fort dès le
démarrage et puis après c'était genre
t'as une caravane et au cul tu coures
pas tu m'as château le truc et on était
à 2 7 on avait perdu les deux premiers
sets et on devait faire le troisième set
et là il sort du terrain du raja verras
que tu de jouer machin truc et puis il
est parti et moi c'était c'était un peu
d'humour c'était et pour la région qui
ont planté leurs chiens qui se faisait
chier avec moi